in late may of 2020
when the death of george floyd sparked
outrage across the united states
it seemed like every major corporation
wanted to join the conversation
including apple twitter sony amazon nike
spotify youtube facebook verizon adobe
zoom t-mobile
nintendo you get the idea
at one moment all of corporate america
was trying to respond to this moment of
anti-black racism but there was one
company that really just their statement
just stood out among the pack and that
was ben and jerry's
it wasn't just nice platitudes it was
actually
legislation that they were calling for
but it's interesting if you go on ben
and jerry's instagram page or twitter
account
they're constantly talking about these
issues and it's not
just when they're prompted it's part of
their actual mission
what's going on is genocide and that
mission has been the cornerstone of the
brand
for over 30 years
but does ben jerry's which in the year
2000 became a subsidiary of a
multinational corporate conglomerate
really care about social justice or is
it all just a clever way
to peddle more pints
hi i'm ben i'm jared you know we may not
have the money to go on tv for 30
seconds but we sure do make some of the
best ice cream you ever tasted
look for us on top of every pipe
in 1978 when lifelong friends ben cohen
and jerry greenfield
opened their first ice cream shop in
burlington vermont
the brand wasn't focused on activism per
se
we never called it a social mission but
the business was values driven from the
from the earliest days
i don't know that we were hardcore
hippies per se
but we certainly believe in
peace and love so when we started as
a little homemade ice cream shop our
idea was to be
a little corner store that would be a
community gathering place
they would donate free ice cream to
non-profit organizations people who were
using the ice cream to
have celebrations or for fundraising
events
the policy was not to turn down anybody
they were basically social justice
activists who had stumbled into
making ice cream and found that they had
a lot of success
at it and as the years went on they
became
more and more skilled and excited to
push various kinds of social causes
our feeling at the time was that
essentially
business is a machine for making money
and that if we want to be of as much
service to the community as possible
what we need to do is give away as much
of our profits as possible
and so we started the ben and jerry's
foundation
the ben and jerry's foundation would
fund community organizations and local
initiatives
helping disadvantaged groups across the
country
and the foundation was to receive seven
and a half percent
of the company's pre-tax profits which
was the highest percentage of any
publicly held company
the corporate average is around one and
a half percent i said five percent
ben said ten percent and we settled on
seven and a half and
you know the investment bankers you know
they were in disbelief because
even five percent of them made no sense
and soon
the founders began integrating their
activism into products
like peace pops a popsicle that would
fund a new anti-war
charity an idea which in itself caused
some conflict
there was always a tension on the board
of directors between those
who wanted to really commit to pursuing
social justice objectives
and those who said no really what we got
to do first of all is make sure
that we do a solid uh financial job of
selling ice cream that we have good
profits but over time the guys and the
business tried to figure out
how to incorporate the values of the
founders
more into the day-to-day business
decisions
and uh that was a real evolution over a
long period of time
uh with some arguing back and forth and
some struggles but eventually led
to the creation of a mission statement
that's based on this concept that was
called
link prosperity the idea behind linked
prosperity
is that as the company prospers
everything and everyone it touches will
prosper
the company would have three goals and
the goals were equally important
and making a profit was only one of the
goals
the second goal was making the best
quality ice cream possible
and the third goal was making a
significant commitment to
social justice and the prosperity of the
communities
that ben and jerry served
but the linked prosperity concept wasn't
entirely new
the executives of businesses in the 50s
and 60s
were considered members of the community
and their businesses were expected to
support their communities
and they were looked down upon if they
did not
participate as leaders in the lives of
their communities
high up in a tower in midtown manhattan
are the offices of an unique
organization
devoted primarily not for making money
but to giving it away
wisely this started to change really in
the late 1960s early 1970s
the change in attitude was highly
identified with an economist named
milton friedman i'm pleased to present
the number one selling book in america
free to choose
please welcome the nobel laureate in
economics milton
friedman and milton friedman's position
was
that the purpose of business is to make
profits um
if you do anything else besides making
as much profit as possible with your
business
you're doing it wrong just tell me where
in the world you find these angels
who are going to organize society for us
well i don't even trust you to do that
i studied that you know in college and
as an mba i didn't believe it then and i
certainly don't believe it now
i mean i never envisioned the
integration of a social mission into a
business the way
that ben did i mean i think he was
really visionary but
in my mind and certainly in ben's mind
there's no way for a business to really
be truly successful
if it's just focused on on making money
it needs to be mindful of its other
constituencies
uh its employees its immediate community
the broader community even the world
and um i think ben and jerry played an
integral role
in hopefully putting to rest milton
friedman's famous quote
cementing the company's priorities
allowed ben and jerry's to integrate
more social activism into the company's
day-to-day operation
like sourcing fair trade ingredients
even if it meant paying higher premiums
partnering with socially responsible
suppliers like a bakery in yonkers
providing jobs to formerly incarcerated
and low-income residents
campaigning against artificial growth
hormones for cows
supporting lgbtq rights promoting
environmental justice
and more it was really about fairness
and justice
and standing up for people
whose voices are often not heard
and that's you know pretty different
from
a corporate approach but i think making
ice cream
allows us to talk with people and
connect with people
about serious things in a pretty fun way
as you give you receive as you help
others
you're helped in return as your business
helps the community
the community supports your business
now that generated you know a lot of
favorable press
uh which we think you know contributes
to people wanting to support
and buy ben and jerry's ice cream but it
didn't originate
uh from people sitting around in the
marketing department saying
hey you know how can we generate some
more press
still over the years the values triad
product
profit and community proved to be a
difficult balance to maintain
especially with increasing pressure to
compete with other super premium ice
cream brands
as the company grew larger and larger
and the
profit margins grew smaller and smaller
more of the shareholders of ben and
jerry's
began to question the company's
commitment
to spending extra money on things like
employee benefits and
charitable gifts and special
arrangements with suppliers and tropical
countries
as a publicly held company you know if
uh
if your stock price is not moving up um
and you become an attractive takeover
you're susceptible to that
there were a number of businesses that
you know expressed an interest in the
company
ben and jerry and a number of people on
the board did not want to sell
and they fought with the other directors
for 18 months
but they eventually lost because not
selling would have meant laying off
probably 40
of their staff so they decided to sell
to unilever
unilever the multinational consumer
goods conglomerate
owns axe dove lipton and about 400 other
brands
the board was able to negotiate a very
unique deal
in which a unique ben and jerry board
would remain and they would have a say
in uh who the ceo
that unilever put in place was and
unilever committed to continue to donate
seven and a half percent
to the ben and jerry's foundation and
then there were some very
uh dark years when unilever really
didn't manage ben and jerry's very
intelligently
and ben and jerry's sort of lost its way
but
about 10 years ago unilever and ben and
jerry's
renegotiated their relationship and
ben jerry's was allowed to fully
recommit to the three-part mission
so when that happened ben and jerry's
really took off and i think the company
is about four times as large in terms of
sales now
as it was when unilever purchased it in
the year 2000.
[Applause]
some of the concepts that ben and jerry
spoke of
early on that investment bankers you
know just
you know went white at are now part of
the vernacular and how businesses
operate today
you know from the fortune 500 on down
earlier this month ben and jerry's
announced their support for the black
lives matter movement
black lives matter members say they
question supporting businesses
who don't take stances against
oppression there's a lot of data that
shows that customers are really looking
for brands and companies to respond to
social activism
and there was one stat that really stood
out to me that two-thirds of ginsees
really look towards the brands and how
they respond to black lives matter
and the way they react will permanently
decide how
they spend with them in the future i
think the company was
able to speak out so strongly and so
clearly
because it had been doing the work
and so that led up to the george floyd
murder and the company
being able to say we must
dismantle white supremacy
one of the most wonderful things is that
we had nothing to do with it people
probably don't realize
ben and i work at the company but we're
not involved in the management we're not
involved in operations
we're kind of pretty faces you know
we're ben and jerry
and the company came out very strong
and it was wonderful
you can imagine how proud ben and i
are that the company is doing things
like that
you